hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday December 24th 2018 oh it's
the most wonderful time of the year you
went to your last [ __ ] Christmas party
and you stopped your fat face
and now your wife is going to drag you
to midnight mass God for [ __ ] bidden
you like me God for [ __ ] bed you just
stay home one day 24 hours just [ __ ]
stay you wake up you get [ __ ] go down
and get some breakfast your scratchy
bullsh right then you mosey on into the
[ __ ] living room you turn on the heat
nice toasty [ __ ] house God for
[ __ ] bid god forbid you laze about
doing [ __ ] off as they say across the
[ __ ] way there right God for [ __ ]
bed now there's always has to be some
[ __ ] social event you have to go to
it's unfuckin believe I'm literally
telling her going like listen this is my
time off this is this is my time off and
then it's just getting immediately
January 2nd 3rd whatever the [ __ ] it is
I'm on a plane to fly to the other side
of the [ __ ] world to essentially do
two shows a night for 10 straight
[ __ ] day so freckles here ain't a
spring chicken anymore can I [ __ ]
just just can I just stay here for
[ __ ] one day one [ __ ] thang I'm
looking at one [ __ ] day well I
thought it would be nice you know what
it is do at the end of the day they
don't give a [ __ ] and if they're not
slowly killing you you're not still
married that's what it is
and all these broads out there [ __ ]
moaning and complaining specifically the
white ladies about how difficult it is
you know the number one stat how long
you live you
that one so go [ __ ] yourself with your
[ __ ] bean-counting whatever the hell
they're doing
I saw some ridiculous tweet there the
other day they were talking about the
top ten [ __ ] gross and comedians and
this other comedian writes all male and
it's just like how is that guy's fault
how the [ __ ] are you gonna put that on
guys
you know if you look at it census
there's more women than there are guys
so I mean I don't know what to tell you
I just don't know what to [ __ ] tell
you you know write a better act you know
ladies get out there and go see some
female comics support it better than you
support the WNBA you know what I mean
[ __ ] sitting there yelling at us all
the time you guys are not exactly team
players out there yeah all right so why
don't you look in your holiday mirror
take off your stupid antlers Jesus what
the [ __ ] it's just everything has just
become that why doesn't this light white
switch work cuz of a white male anyways
this is the boohoo generation anyways
happy holidays everybody I thought I
would this was guy was like man this is
[ __ ] new you this is Christmas Eve I
don't have [ __ ] to do and this just it's
just always gonna be something just
every [ __ ] it's like how is there
always something even God every [ __ ]
six days he had one [ __ ] day where he
didn't do [ __ ] and he created the
universe I'm a [ __ ] ant on a [ __ ]
uh I'm a universe on the top in top of a
[ __ ] pin whatever those [ __ ] pot
heads say there's a line I'm gonna use
to my wife just out of curiosity how am
i working harder than the Creator the
[Music]
creator of the universe gets more days
off a year than I do
how the [ __ ] does that work I think
you're being a little dramatic I don't
think I am take out a calendar oh boy
this is what I do now I just I just go
out to the garage its soundproof now cuz
I got my drum kit here and I just I lose
my [ __ ] and then I come out and I just
[ __ ] put a smile on my face like
[ __ ] Chuck Woolery that's what I do
and I laugh and I rub my brow like oh
god you're killing me that that's that's
[ __ ] incredible you know what I want
you know what I want in the new year I
want one day off a week okay God needs a
[ __ ] one day I should have to maybe
that's why we only work a five-day
workweek right because if we only took
one day off then we would say that we
were on god's level do you realize the
amount of days off that I don't have
puts me that I'm actually working harder
than God and a couple hundred years ago
or 26 years ago in the South I would
actually be killed for this what I would
be doing was be could be considered
sacrilegious that I was putting myself
on a higher plane that I could actually
sit down with God and be like what you
do oh yeah well that's pretty impressive
there Almighty maker of everything but
let me ask you this what's that big
goose egg on day number 7 on Sunday what
were you doing then oh yeah you put your
big [ __ ] creative feet up then yeah
you got your holy hammock over there
didn't you well guess what I kept going
huh look what happened to your creation
you know you think if God could come
down and he'd have enough time to
[ __ ] bang a virgin you know he could
maybe [ __ ] yell down my chimney every
once in a while and be like hey hey
sweetheart
ease up you know he's up on it maybe
they could do that to all the [ __ ]
married women out there how about you
guys how about you do that in the
[ __ ] new year ladies I know we have
all this [ __ ] work to do God knows
I've seen enough award shows this year
of women giving me lectures on how to be
a [ __ ] man how funny is that
right if you're a good man but you're a
bad man and the bad man says dude shut
the [ __ ] up and get your trophy jesus
[ __ ] christ the [ __ ] lectures and
all these [ __ ] guys with their balls
tucked behind the p90x thighs just
sitting there in the crowd that tuxedo I
don't want to get in trouble
I'm telling you somebody's got to do it
out here in Hollywood one of these
awards shows somebody has to throw a
dinner roll just has to happen I mean if
it's happened to me I why I giving equal
rights all right already
all right anyways you wouldn't know this
but I was actually I was actually in a
good mood ten minutes ago until I
realized there was yet another [ __ ] I
got everything done
okay the [ __ ] trees decorated the
[ __ ] lights are up all the gifts are
wrapped the last [ __ ] gift that I was
getting my wife the cherry on top the
cherry cherry on top all right you know
I just [ __ ] it let me just finish that
thought I finally got that gift I have
it there it is here it is this is what
you made to me all right now can I have
a 24-hour period period but I just stay
in the house I stay in the house
nobody's coming over
nobody's fixing anything I don't have to
get in the car go down and go [ __ ]
get something I stay right here
I don't read I watch TV I [ __ ] relax
I put I put my feet up and for one day
I'm treated like a king is that is that
asking too much this is like one of
those stupid topics on one of those
[ __ ] lady shows ladies do we need to
treat our men like kings occasionally
I'm not saying you're not a queen that's
a pity anyways what are you guys doing
for Christmas
I'm still anal this is my last podcast
holding my headphone jack here like like
a terrorist you don't thump ooh the top
and I don't know that I guess my life
gets easier I'm really playing the
victim on all this I should just be like
no I'm not doing that and you know it's
funny my wife would have no problem with
it so what does that go back to out goes
back to the childhood that's what it
goes back to I grew up with the sit down
and shut the [ __ ] up we had that carved
into wood and hung up on the wall sit
down and shut the [ __ ] up but now I get
it now I get it
you gotta get you gotta get married and
you have to have a kid to truly
understand your father then you get it
it's like I totally get him now I
totally get the guy you know just coming
home what I I don't know come on get out
of here anyway speaking of broads
Jessica Kherson everybody you know you
want to talk about somebody who you
ladies should be out there [ __ ]
supporting so there's not more people
whining about the tour money that people
are getting honestly out there
Jessica Kherson man oh woman this is one
of the [ __ ] funniest comedians out
there for a long [ __ ] time all things
comedy we're doing is special with her
taping January 11th at the Highline
Ballroom in New York City I'm so excited
for this I'm telling you you watch what
we're doing in all things County
Pulver's he's special by the way he's
streaming again on Comedy Central it's
broken all their records for streaming
online and it was named one of the top
ten specials on interrobang of 2018
that's a congratulations to the pride of
Trenton New Jersey Paul virzi and then
we got we got Ian Edward
coming up we got Jessica cursor with you
tell week we got him telling you telling
you we got some [ __ ] we got some we
got some we got some good specials
coming up in 2019 can you believe that's
the end of this decade
these last two decades have flown by
because they haven't really named him
you know where was the 60s it was the
70s it was the 80s it was the 90s and
there was just nothing it was all about
oh my god y2k is is my [ __ ] flip
phone not gonna work how will my
refrigerator work at one second past
12:00 a.m. huh will we're gonna party
like it's 1999 still be playing on my
stereo that's what we worried about and
then all of a sudden nothing really
[ __ ] happened there was no Armageddon
I think a couple people's like little uh
one of those little handheld things with
the stylus that everybody loved to have
him back in the I think a few of those
crashed but everything else was fine
everything else was fine and we were so
relieved
dad we never named the decade and we
just started invading people I don't
know what Trump is doing right now but I
love bringing troops back I'm all for
that you know considering all these
[ __ ] wars have effectively bankrupt
at this company company this country
well it's just a big corporation now
isn't it yeah bring them all back bring
them all back legalize weed put up some
solar panels put the Middle East out of
business export the [ __ ] weed get
everybody high right pay off the dead
everybody thinks what chill again that's
what I would do all right in any country
that still has a problem with us we'll
set up some free t-shirts a couple of
sex dolls and it'll be all but whatever
the [ __ ] Trump did with that [ __ ]
fatty over there in North Korea whatever
the [ __ ] he did with him they went over
there they sat down you know they had
some jalapeno poppers right he got all
right he got he brought over a couple of
[ __ ] blond hair blue eye
was okay they gave him the old sweet and
sour chicken there that's a hooker move
anyways I I don't know what to tell you
I don't know what's going on in the
world of politics I don't pretend to pay
attention I just you know I'm a man of
the people
who doesn't want to see the people
that's who I am I'm the man of people
who just wants to stay at home in his
[ __ ] house
alright that's all I want to do you know
I like the regular people I like the
regular guy in any country just walking
down the street and he's excited cuz he
has that little moment to himself wait
maybe I'll go into the pub here I have a
quick little [ __ ] beer and a shot all
right come on with a stupid look on my
face
my wife's talking to me I'm not
listening I'll just kiss her on the
forehead pinch your cheek and faceplant
under the couch anybody who's doing that
and any culture any races any continent
you're all right with me I believe you
know isn't that what most people are
doing I'm most people you know you got a
family you just want to [ __ ] and feel
okay you know it would be great if all
the people of the world just looked at
the world leaders and just said hey hey
hey hey relax relax
settle down everything's gonna be fine
okay you're in you're in a palace you're
in a big white house okay everything's
fine you have plenty
you have your own jet okay [ __ ] relax
everybody take it down a few right well
that'd be nice if you could just get
everybody on the same page but you can't
can put up a [ __ ] YouTube video
without everybody screaming and yelling
at each other I missed most of that
Kansas City Seattle Seahawks game but
I'm gonna talk about it nonetheless all
right I'll tell you right now I would be
concerned if I was a fan of these Kansas
City Chiefs from Kansas City Missouri
not Kansas City Kansas Kansas City
Missouri I would be very concerned
okay sandy Reed is a great coach but
when he goes up against other great
coaches he's got to come out of there
with a win and he read up against old
sneaky pete carroll Oh Pistol Pete boom
out of USC right as the wolf was at the
door ran out the back door right up to
Seattle Oh sneaky Pete you know Pete
Carroll's how good that guy looks you
know he's a year older than Bill
Belichick he wouldn't know be Cara looks
like he's about 55 the man's pushing 70
great shape full head of hair you know
not a line on his face it crossed the
way you got Andy read the every man
looks like he drives a [ __ ] snowplow
you know when you just knew you just
knew Pete Carroll was gonna figure out a
way to get it though
you know what everybody's flipping out
about Patrick Mahone's you forgetting
about Russell Wilson you know you just
taking the guy for [ __ ] granted I
would say that's the Seattle Seahawks of
the 7 7 & 1 whatever the [ __ ] their
record is they're they're that team
nobody wants to play oh Jesus who the
[ __ ] is that yeah I know who the [ __ ]
that is I don't know some somebody over
in Asia got my [ __ ] cell phone number
and every day you know I don't pick it
up and then I listen to the voicemail
and I hear this lady's voice just go now
you'll call me got that out there but
the bank for one 800 second I don't know
what it is for but no I did maybe it's
it's Kim Jong Un's [ __ ] secretary
this sick of me making fun of him on the
podcast what would you do if that guy
called in you know [ __ ] scared I
would be keeping always in the unknown
the whole lot of [ __ ] part of the
world to have a dictator call you up I
think about the first syllable that word
dick all right
telling you right now there's a reason
why that guy's a dick maybe that came
from dictator did it should I look that
up
that interest you um anyways I missed
most of that game but she just he just
[ __ ] knew you knew Pete Carroll
wasn't gonna sit around and get his
[ __ ] ass fired in Seattle no matter
how many people he lost and I got to
commend that owner for sticking with
them they know what they got up there
Pete Carroll's he's gonna coach for like
what do you think another 10 years
he's obviously hitting the elliptical
every day he's eating the steamed
vegetables the guy's a beast what do you
guys put him in the coaching history I
mean like you got to put them in I know
he's got one though he needed that
second 100 we need you need that second
ring you know to get in the conversation
anyways you know something else I'm
getting sick of this [ __ ] Miami
Dolphins every [ __ ] year with this
undefeated thing in the 72 dolphins
still go on yet 1970 [ __ ] - when are
we gonna quit glorifying that they went
undefeated in 1972 with two white
running backs
it's how [ __ ] long ago that was Jesus
Christ 1972 they barely invented the
frisbee the frisbee was like a decade
old I mean you haven't done [ __ ] since
then listen to the Dolphins fans talking
[ __ ] about that that's literally would
be like listening to the Knicks fan
they'll be particularly if they they
started talking some [ __ ] they they
haven't wanted since 73 they got a
[ __ ] year on you um anyways I don't
think my Patriots I don't know man I
don't know than that dude we got from
the Browns poor guy relapsed and now do
you know you just hope he goes and he
gets you know I'm self taking care of
there I hope they don't suspend him for
good I'm hoping that guy has a full
recovery comes back and [ __ ] has the
career we should have had but uh I don't
know I don't know I'm looking at the
Patriots now that we have home field I
figure we can win one I don't know about
another one but you
never know with Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick but if we're not gonna win I
want us to lose in the first round so I
can enjoy all these other teams that I
really want to see do well I would love
to see Kansas City or San Diego how
about the Cleveland Browns how great
would it si can they make the playoffs
like I said I got the kid now so I watch
as much as I can
I saw Baker Mayfield staring down his
old [ __ ] coach a bit of a classless
[ __ ] move you know to be in the prime
of your physical life to be staring down
somebody who looks like they take
Geritol
but you also got to love somebody that
plays for the Browns at the quarterback
position having a little bit of swagger
seeing happy Brown fans seeing Brown
fans with hope you know that late in the
game I mean I haven't seen that I I want
to say since the 1980s my up when they
played in Municipal Stadium so that's
great to see
I love seeing the Texans doing well even
though they lost to the Eagles I was
weird yesterday having to root for the
Eagles I came on the last time I was in
a position where I had to root for the
Eagles I got to feel what it felt like
to be a [ __ ] Eagles fan yesterday no
thanks I'll pass on that [ __ ] [ __ ]
can you just put somebody away
what else did I see I think that was it
I saw a little bit of that Steelers game
I watched a little bit of the Bruins
playing The Hartford Whalers did we lose
that game by the way we were up like two
to one and then you know my kid woke up
from her nap
Bruins verse hurricanes did we lose that
game ah [ __ ] me oh we got smoked in the
second period three goals to one so that
put them up four to three and then they
scored another one and I you sons of
[ __ ] I love that they played the was
it called the the brass something or
other
they played that the old whaler song
whenever they used to score goals by pi
pi pi pi
but Papa Papa Papa you guys remember
that Wailers gold song was it there was
the brass something or other
brass bonanza they'd score a goal right
and then they'd play this song right
here if I can unmute it
[Music]
let's hold that's how old I am this song
was played in national hockey league
games
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh I was at the pro
level I'll tell you what's weird I just
realized this I tweeted about it do you
know the Hartford Whalers have been the
Carolina Hurricanes for one year longer
than they were ever the Hartford Whalers
how sad is that
they were the Hartford Whalers for from
1979 to 1997 so what is that how many
years is that that's 70 years 17 years
18 seasons and from 1997 on they've been
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] Carolina
Hurricanes I you know kills me as I
never went to a Hartford Whalers game it
was right down the street
I could have got there and like I don't
know how long but it just seems so far
away to me back then I was living just
outside of Boston I could have got there
no traffic in like 45 minutes an hour
and I never went one time my buddy had
tickets and he's like oh but I already
asked this other guy and then the other
guy said he wanted to go I'm like I had
no worries it was a Bruins verse
Hartford Whalers the Hartford Whalers
pepper pepper what about the Houston
Oilers fight zone Houston Oilers Houston
Oilers Houston Oilers now
[Music]
how much work that horn players get back
in the day that's not really true you've
yet to win a Super Bowl
oh here it is there you go there you go
I was watching this whole thing on
[ __ ] Earl Campbell I was like I
remember that song that's how easy it
was back then
every song started to say 'we got guy
and then they'd some horns came in and
then some kinda to Bush is going both
that's it then now you know because
these [ __ ] DJ's they stripped all of
that away and now all we're left with is
just the tuba bass line basically
Bom Bom Bom Bom Bom Bom Bom and then the
trumpet comes in two trillion dollars in
national debt anyways I don't what I'm
talking about here everybody that felt
good at the top of the podcast might I
might have came up came in a little hot
but it felt good to get that out of me
you know I'm gonna [ __ ] work out and
eat well I haven't drank in thirty days
that might be another part of the
problem
thirty [ __ ] days three tree zero
so Christmas tomorrow is gonna be a 31
an official you know month no boozing
and all I got to do is just get through
that day you know my wife is trying to
convince me to have a you know friend of
ours got this there's really nice
bottle of wine but I'm just gonna say
enough I'll be like yeah let's drink it
on Valentine's Day I'm just gonna keep
pushing it pushing it pushing it pushing
it cuz you know I'm an old dad and I got
a [ __ ] grow up I got a lot of growing
up to do and a lot of yelling that I did
and all the [ __ ] I did at the top of
the podcast you know something you know
something they'd had more to do with me
than anybody else and that's what I'm
realizing I need to learn to express
what it is that I want what it is that I
need and I got to stop acting like I'm
[ __ ] 22 years old
alright it's over bill grow the [ __ ] up
houston oilers bad bad bad bad bad bad
this what the [ __ ] bill 50 years old
this is what I look up online remember
this game that's what the [ __ ] I do just
become this sad man anyways my lovely
wife is gonna throw down my lovely wife
who deserves such a better guy is
throwing down she's making some lamb
chops tomorrow which is gonna be [ __ ]
delicious and I'm just drinking the club
soda that's all I'm doing
and I try to maybe play a little bit of
drums early in the day that's it all
right and I already know you know my
kid's gonna have a great Christmas she
doesn't quite get what Santa Claus is
but she loves the tree so next year it's
gonna be on you know it's gonna be it's
gonna be a lot of fun
so anyways let me read a little bit of
advertising here by the way thank you
for listening what are you doing that
you listening to the [ __ ] you're not
with your family huh in between
relationships
did you just that were you sent on an
assignment I hope your work is if your
were then the top of this podcast was
[ __ ] cathartic for you all right
darling
dude
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to look feel and smell your best
and you never have to go to a store by
the way how the [ __ ] is guys making all
this money instead how is that sexist
they're not forcing anybody to go see
their tours
you know they had great years as
comedians that you just have to come in
there and you can [ __ ] go out [ __ ]
write a great act people will come
am i whining cuz I wasn't on the Liz
Dollar Shave Club dollar shake Darla
shave club dude take four WA Jalla shade
Club has everything you need to look
feel and smell your best and you never
have to go to the stillwe that's because
they deliver everything you need right
to you do and they keep you fully
stocked on what you use so you don't run
out here's how it works Dollar Shave
Club has everything you need to get
ready no matter what you're getting
ready for alright a dinner a Christmas
party a bank robbery you wanna you know
he really scared me with the gun but I
have to tell you he really smelt great
Jolly shave club they have you covered
from head to toe for you hey yeah your
skin your face you name it they have it
and they will automate and they have
this new program where they
automatically keep you stocked up on the
products you use so whatever you do
don't you know something and that might
save your life one day you hit your head
on the tub and people just see all this
bathroom products stocking up with your
[ __ ] door we should go in there and
check on you know they'll catch you a
mid seat you determine what you want and
when you want it and it shows up right
at your door from once a month to once
every six months plus with their
handsome discount the more you buy the
more you save and right now Dollar Shave
Club is a great thing too for uh for
those doomsdayers you know what I mean
the Armageddon prepares you got to make
sure you have plenty of toiletries I
think you could have all the [ __ ]
soup in the world
but if you can't wipe your ash what do
you do peel the label off the [ __ ]
chicken noodle soup you need someone
wiped cherries plus with their home
discount the more you buy the more you
save and right now Dollar Shave Club has
a bunch of starter sets you can try for
just $5 like their oral care kit ladies
after their that the restock box ships
regular size products at regular prices
get your status for just five dollars
right now at dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / burr Oh
who's texting me who is texting me Oh
somebody wishing me a Merry Christmas
isn't that nice that's the kind of thing
that you like around Christmas you know
what I mean hey how come only Santa
Claus rides in the sleigh why does his
wife have to stay home with those little
people I think it's time for a female
Santa Claus all right my bookie
hey are you doing a full seasons here oh
it's time to get into the action with my
bookie don't be a gabagool there don't
be that guy with no routing interests as
your relatives or friends sit around
watching the game ain't not this year
what when there are a record 41 ball
games o to bet on including the national
championship game on January 7th it
really is the most wonderful time of the
year to go gambling with your children's
college tuition let's have a beer okay
make sure you're ready for the daily
action by signing up at my pokey today
they pay fast when you win ownership
really cares about good customer service
and they offer you the craziest props
where you bet is just important as who
you're betting on and if you want to
make money hey what makes a buddy during
the bowl season you got to go to my
bookie oh I trust them evidently
according to the copy but you know
have to take my word for it check them
out for yourself join now at my bookie
Oh
my bookie will offer you a 50% deposit
bonus to make sure you have a nice big
role football season all right get the
[ __ ] out of here use promo code xxxx
xxxx
I guess that's BER they didn't put it in
here when you deposit to activate the
offer that's promo code ber I'm gonna
guess at my bookie oh you don't want to
get the [ __ ] out how's your mother you
play you win you get paid try this let's
try to tell us alright there you go
that's the that's the advertiser let's
get in on some questions here can I go a
little short here can I go a little
short can I come up a little bit short
Houston Oilers Houston Oilers number one
[Music]
my ticket prices would have been higher
but men came in and made him lower
that's why I'm not on that list
I would have played a bigger venue but
men came and chased the crowd away
that's sexism name checked in a rap song
hmm a billy goat gruff just giving you a
heads up that you are mentioned by name
and a new song iron claw buys our face
inspected deck from the wu-tang wu-tang
clan and 7l and esoteric from Boston
Ghost Face killer is on the track but
unfortunately the mention of got the
filter of Bilborough obviously comes
from the white dude from Boston well
what's wrong with that what are you
ashamed of being a cracker keep up the
good work and maybe you'll have better
luck next time
oh Jesus look at this this poor bastard
he doesn't like his [ __ ]
cream-colored skin that's gotten him his
[ __ ] townhouse huh
what's the matter are you guilty with
all your privilege you should go on tour
evidently you'll make more money than
the Broads out there
I like how you totally just [ __ ]
completely disregarded this guy as a
musician just because he was white I
mean well I don't understand what's
going on in the world right now okay can
we just [ __ ] you know if somebody's
good just say they're good can we do
that can we stop with the [ __ ] bean
cone and that [ __ ] you know I love that
you know this business was like
completely racist and sexist homophobic
and all of that type of [ __ ] and now to
correct it now they're gonna go the
other [ __ ] direction and just it's
just like they don't know how to do it
it's like it's not about an algorithm
it's not a formula just whoever's the
best just give it to them whoever makes
you HOT Singh hire them that's it names
okay where my boys versus girls dear
Billy wrong balls
Oh God my balls are wrong too I thought
it was just my mouth now my [ __ ] nuts
are dragged into it an accessory to the
crime you mentioned a few times how glad
how you're glad you have a girl versus a
boy I have one of each and I can tell
you for sure that is that it's not the
case all right so basically what you're
gonna do is what I did I based the whole
world on my wonderful daughter so
evidently you don't have a good daughter
so now my daughter's gonna be bad
not that boys are better that just
different girls are very emotional and
their attitude is way more defiant in
different ways ironically misuse of the
word parenthesis my four best friends
all have one of each and as well and we
have had this talk a bunch of times all
right now he has numbers on me all right
now I'm losing we're all different
people and parents and have different
ethnic backgrounds he's got a great
algorithm going here and one conclusion
we came to quickly was that it's a
trade-off some things are way easier
with boys you're a man who's been around
so you know that there are major
differences in the ways boys and girls
and men and women process things dude
can you just let me enjoy when she's a
kid I don't need to know that she's
gonna hate me when she's eight
my daughter is very kind and very polite
but at times she can be a bit how do I
say intense once again I'm not trying to
convince you that boys are better just
that you'll see when girls can be a
handful no I didn't think it was going
to be an easy ride I'm just saying that
boys are animals dead lunatics like the
first 10 years of their life there are
eight seven eight years of it they're
there they're lunatics can you give me
that sir now I got to respect you
because you're further down the road
than I am see got the experience on me
I'm still a rookie here I'm about ready
to start the sophomore jinx yeah number
two oh no my god I am already two years
in um next month again not a blanket
statement I'm sure your daughter will
continue to be an angel but she has
yours and Nia's Spitfire genes and she
will surely show it in a few years if
she hasn't already no she has she is and
I'm happy you're glad you had a daughter
and not trying to convince you otherwise
so don't call me a [ __ ] I just think
you're being a bit naive go [ __ ]
yourself
I just [ __ ] call me naive you argue
like a broad but you see this little he
said you know I'm gonna tell you
something but you have to promise you're
not gonna get mad I'm not trying to
convince you otherwise so don't call me
a [ __ ] but now I'm gonna call you naive
food for thought oh go [ __ ] yourself
that whole [ __ ] thing that guy can go
[ __ ] himself hey not trying to be this
not trying to be that just saying your
way [ __ ] wrong I'm not trying to
convince you otherwise just saying
you're [ __ ] you know you're a bit
[ __ ] naive that's some food for
thought here's some food for thought why
don't you go [ __ ] yourself all right
you're not me and I'm not you and I'm
very happy for you and your United
Benetton colors of [ __ ] friends that
you have do you guys can all go [ __ ]
yourselves
alright jesus [ __ ] christ I mean I
got to be honest oh you didn't really
tell me anything that I didn't already
know women are more emotional gee thank
you for that Jim I never noticed I never
noticed that men and women
process things differently now you know
something now I'm gonna be a [ __ ] let's
go back to this I have one of each not
that they're better they're just
different you had like your hands up the
whole time you know if you [ __ ] gun
belt around your ankles and then you
took a giant [ __ ] alright it really bugs
me I like it better on people go hit
pill you don't know you know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
alright this then at least I know where
you stand granted I'll still get upset
alright shitty new bosses I already know
I'm gonna handle what my daughter gets
upset with me I'll just be alright
alright I get it
they'll talk to your mother I don't
understand these things hey there hey
there Billy no boss my company just got
bought out I have a boss that worked for
Netflix efforts for family my company
just got bought out and this job I love
will be majorly affected by this
corporate [ __ ] house I've had a lot of
freedom to be creative and innovative
but that's all gonna go away yes it is
here comes the algorithms
bump-bump Bob but up and up up don't
have fun to [ __ ] each other we're a
[ __ ] corporation for this [ __ ] in the
drinking water
who cares if babies have birth defects
I've been told that there will be a set
of guidelines put in place that will
essentially rob me from all the joy I
had it's really heartbreaking because
I've just reached the point where I am
able to make good money the new bosses
came in and started talking to us like
they were exist there were existing
problems that needed to be fixed this is
of course ridiculous because they bought
they bought us because of how well we
were run and how innovative we've been
should I just quit now so I don't have
to deal with everything that is to come
I've saved a lot of money but it's a
unique job and I'm not sure I'll be able
to find anything like it in the near
future well then I wouldn't quit it
I know something god bless anybody in
the corporate world that deals with
stuff like that and you know stone could
be like like when they come in you can't
tell them to shut the [ __ ] up
because what's going to happen is
they're gonna ruin the company they're
gonna make it worse and no one's ever
gonna step to them and say that you know
you guys took a great thing and you made
it less great slash [ __ ] the whole thing
up no one ever tells them that because
all they do is look at the bottom line I
have to you know I don't know I I've
watched enough [ __ ] documentaries and
[ __ ] and listened to enough people like
they have to just like corporations the
way they do business needs to be fixed
because it's just too [ __ ] runaway
train it affects our foreign policy it
affects people's quality of life
everything from how much money they make
to like the environment how polluted our
not polluted it is and until you get a I
don't know because politicians have
their money pouring out of their pockets
like they've just [ __ ] their
treasonous people that just yeah they
exist without [ __ ] borders that
they're the worst they are the [ __ ]
worse we can agree on that boys versus
girls who gives a [ __ ] just the
corporate mindset it's just [ __ ]
insane
Merry Christmas everybody my girlfriend
at the aspiring model dear bill same
[ __ ] different toilet I'll rush through
the generic intro I'm dating the girl of
my dreams you've been exclusive for
three months but I've been dating for a
total of eight months she's gorgeous her
beauty has no boundaries I've been in
other serious relationships before but
none quite like this I'm truly in love
with my best friend like something
Nicholas Sparks [ __ ] up whoa who the
[ __ ] is that now I got to look that up
he says yada yada yada you get the gist
who the [ __ ] is Nicholas Sparks that he
shits out models all right I gotta look
this up you staying all yours Nicholas
Sparks not movies you [ __ ] [ __ ] ah
god I [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate apples
[ __ ] [ __ ] you want to talk about a
corporation that just infiltrated my
whole life now everything I have is like
run by those [ __ ]
this stupid round building he's a
novelist what the fighting I wouldn't
have well no wonder I didn't know who he
was the guy writes books alright hang on
a second
merry Christmas to all my friends and
readers so crazy bytes books Nicholas
Sparks is one of the world's most
beloved storytellers all his books have
been New York Times bestsellers Jesus
Christ and I don't need a back in the
day I knew who the I would know about a
guy like this there's just no more
bookstores he's got a sweater over a
button-down shirt he's leaning up
against a [ __ ] pole on a dock I mean
this guy is a quality human being
Nicholas Sparks is one of the world's
most beloved storytellers all of his
books have been New York Times
bestsellers with over a hundred and five
million copies sold worldwide in more
than 50 languages including 75 million
in the United States alone Sparks wrote
one also a male sparks wrote one of his
best-known stories The Notebook of Jesus
oh I get what you say you're like living
a chick-flick okay I get it now all
right
something Nicholas Sparks [ __ ] up okay
so I guess he puts out a lot of product
anyway she's an aspiring model and
pretty good at her craft her and the
camera get along great
anyway her lack of experience says
they're still getting offers from
unknown photographers in particular a
guy she's done a few shoots with in the
past this time he wants to shoot nude
and without pay [ __ ] no obviously I have
a problem with this I want it she
doesn't need to be naked don't do that I
want I wanted to pursue her passion but
this in particular doesn't sit right
with me I've never met this guy he's not
paying her to shoot and what's her
reasoning for wanting naked pictures of
my girl I've watched enough Jerry
Springer and Forensic Files not to trust
it definitely she talked to me wanting
my blessing which makes me feel worse I
told her my unease about it but in the
end I
trust her and we'll be okay if she goes
ahead she wants to model so I'll have to
get over things like this no you don't
but right now it's a tough pill to
swallow any advice or comic relief you
could provide would be appreciated
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
now [ __ ] this piece of [ __ ] and then
he's gonna sell these for these naked
photos of her when she [ __ ] gets
somewhere this guy's a piece of [ __ ]
he's not even given a cab fare to get
over there no [ __ ] this guy with his
artistic nude shots this guy's a [ __ ]
creep he's going over to her apartment
that guy is a [ __ ] creep he's a
[ __ ] creep he's gonna jerk off to the
pictures okay any first-year [ __ ] cop
would tell you that all right you got to
go worst-case scenario to [ __ ] this guy
all day long you have to tell you you're
your girlfriend that you know being a
being a model doesn't mean getting naked
you don't have to do that [ __ ] that's
just [ __ ] creepy [ __ ]
there's no [ __ ] reason ever for them
to do that [ __ ] ever give me a scenario
why they would have to be naked they're
a [ __ ] model you're modeling clothes
you standing next to a refrigerator
being like wow oddly you know what I
really like that refrigerator now
because that woman so beautiful you know
have to [ __ ] sit there with your tits
and your clam out what the [ __ ] is that
for why why does she have to be naked
Jesus Christ a [ __ ] two-piece bathing
suits gonna show pretty much everything
no I would say no I would say I got a
bad feeling that this is gonna come back
I want you to have a great career this
is gonna come back and bite you in the
ass your bare ass all right this you
going over to this guy's apartment he's
not paying you and you have to get naked
and he's taking photos and this is
somehow gonna further your career he's
gonna what send these [ __ ] photos
around your parents are gonna see him
this is a bad [ __ ] move
say what I just said about the angers
the f-word all right where's dessert
dear Billy Baker balls my aunt makes a
peppermint cake every year and every
year I look at it like why would anyone
want to take the taste like toothpaste
was wondering if you had strong feelings
about any desserts that have crossed
your holiday table merry Christmas to
you and your two angels ah let's see
here I don't like coffee so I don't like
anything coffee flavored I don't like
marshmallow
I don't like s'mores yeah I don't like
anything with marshmallows I don't like
I don't like candy in my cookies like
mmm cookies or snicker bar crunches like
that's just this unholy [ __ ] it's like
you're already eating a cookie do you
got a jam a [ __ ] I don't like
anything that I don't like I scoop ice
cream with a cook I mean they gonna have
ice cream gonna have a [ __ ] cookie
I'm really not gonna have any of that
[ __ ] anymore because I kind of got sugar
out of my life although the holidays has
come back a little bit the first time
you have something with sugar after you
haven't been eatin it you like dude what
the [ __ ] is this it's terrible it's
terrible for you
but I like pie I don't mind a little
whipped cream on my pie or I mean an ala
mode you know I don't mind [ __ ] like
that ah [ __ ] my wife told me to make a
pie that Christ never ends does it
when will it ever end when will it ever
end who's that the Kingston where have
all the flowers gone wherever there's
something in gold a long long time ago
the Kingston Trio yeah I'm not into
marshmallows I'm not into [ __ ] coffee
flavored anything and I don't like I
love the way coffee smells oh and I
don't like yeah yeah I don't like
incestuous desserts where the [ __ ]
cookie [ __ ] the candy or the candy
gets inside the cookie it's just
it's just I mean that's just for super
super super fat people that's like their
speedball like it's not enough to do
heroin or just do coke you got have you
got to [ __ ] do a speedball you know
speaking of which how about that
Aerosmith song combination huh is that a
great song walking on Gucci wearing he
say for the wrong barely stay on kind of
us I'm so goddamn gone Dollar Shave Club
Dollar Shave Club has already talked
about this right did I
I think I did yeah my bookie already did
that I did both the reeds well that's
right I was doing the UH shitty new boss
what are you what a way to start the
year worse desert oh that's it
am I done I can't be done
that's only 5150 wow it was almost 5150
um anyways you know what sucks is we
didn't do a holiday card until late this
year you got to do it right on
Thanksgiving that's my buddy told me
last night the great al man whoo go let
me know that man does everything right
um let's see what I can [ __ ] about
for the next few minutes here oh god
yeah I was at this [ __ ] party last
night I can't say the comedians name
I'll tell it someday on his podcast so I
met this I'm at this holiday party last
night last night was a great party by
the way
I had a [ __ ] awesome time at that you
know to the point I was one of the last
people to go and there was a comic there
and he had lost like 20 pounds and he
was already skinny six I get lost 20
pounds and the [ __ ] psyched right
he's one of those people that he then
keeps tabs on everybody else so he sees
me go over to the buffet and I got like
four shrimp and I got a bunch of lettuce
it's like salad or whatever and he's
looking at me because that's all you're
eating and I knew that was [ __ ] with
him because he's one of those people
like you know in in order for him to
feel good about being in shape other
people have to be a little out of shape
you know he's got to I walk god I wish
he would be laughing right I'm not being
a dick to him he loves his [ __ ] right so
he goes that's all you're eating that
I knew what the [ __ ] he was doing I was
just like yeah man a guy can't eat that
other stuff man I'll have to take a nap
so long story short we're there for like
four hours and I get [ __ ] hungry so
my wife you know fixed herself a nice
plate and I saw she had a slider and I
got god I'd love one of those so I
[ __ ] go up and I go to the this is
like [ __ ] two two and a half hours
after I talked to him about eating the
lettuce and the shrimp right and I grab
a slider and I'm reaching for a
quesadilla like a little triangle
quesadilla and I just hear this guy way
off across the room and I know it's him
so I'm like this [ __ ] this guy
right so I deliberately ignored him
because I wanted to see how [ __ ]
important it was for him to rub it in
that I was eating bad and there was a
bunch of people talking him was loud so
I deliberately turned and walked towards
him and I was looking down at the plate
and he's going louder there you go there
you go bar there you go there you go
like that and I [ __ ] looked up and I
put my hand on his shoulder and I was
like dude I heard you the first time I
just wanted to see how much joy you
would get into it he was crying laughing
I was like what the [ __ ] is wrong we had
the funniest [ __ ] exchange last night
right I was talking to him and I said
something he totally explain this place
he's goes why and he kind of stepped
towards me when he said and I said dude
don't get my [ __ ] face in stuck it in
argumented oh I'm just making a [ __ ]
statement you [ __ ]
right and then he goes I wasn't getting
in your face or whatever right and then
like it took me a half hour to process
and I was like oh wait this guy's been
to a zillion concerts he plays guitar
his hearing his shot and I walked over
and I started laughing I was like dude I
didn't realize you a little hard of
hearing I thought you were being a dick
and we would just laughing our asses off
that he was so [ __ ] old that now he
goes why when people talk to him and
then I'm such a [ __ ] defensive [ __ ]
that I got in his grille like he was
being an [ __ ] to me I'm not even
drinking in that
happened oh my god that made my night
there you go there you go / there you go
there you go stuff your face so I can
feel good about being in shape
I'll tell if there's one thing that I
love in life it's a miserable [ __ ] and
this guy is he's right you probably
figured out who it is at this point
miserable [ __ ] plays guitar is happy
when someone else is failing him at this
point he's one of my favorite people in
this business anyways L as I threatened
as I threatened I've been feeling like
going back to church and I'm going to
church today or this evening I should
say this is one of the things I have to
do today that I'm actually looking
forward to I actually really enjoy going
to church with my whole family because
that's something I did when I was
growing up I don't believe a lot of it
but the the underlying message before it
goes takes a left turn and we have to go
kill some people as all religion seems
to lead to God loves you and you love
him and he just wants to love you and be
happy and these other people we need to
kill I take it just dislike the it just
hurt it's a nice reminder to be a good
person and I would like to I would like
to start going again you know I'm trying
to turn the [ __ ] ship around I live
day eight he is it hedonistic I don't
know what the [ __ ] it was but I have
boozed way too much over the last
through my 40s and I said I was gonna
slow down on my fifty I was gonna go
stay in my 50s all right I never did
down dog lightly I want to [ __ ] eat
better and I just want to stop [ __ ]
boozing oh god am I gonna do that thing
am I gonna be now that I'm a dad am I
gonna start pretending to be who you
know who I'm not am I gonna set an
example
I'm not gonna lie to my kid God knows I
can't get plenty of [ __ ] podcasts to
listen to dad did you drink oh yeah oh
yeah oh yes I did yes yes yes I did
and I did it too much and I wish I
didn't it was a mistake
anyways having said that how long is
this booze no booze weren't gonna go if
I get through tomorrow I feel like I can
get through all of January and then I'll
be getting ready to do a special
somewhere I gotta figure out where I'm
gonna tape it and then it won't drink so
I'll probably go like to April now be
there be a good thing
get my liver a nice [ __ ] break you
know I mean like what's-his-face Urban
Meyer so my livers like every couple of
years it's got to take a break you know
for health reasons I'm actually going to
the last game that Legend is going to be
coaching man that's something else where
do you put him in the lexicon of great
college coaches of all time man you got
to put that guy up there and the fact
that he was dealing with that [ __ ]
cyst in his head to the point he had
like bend over at the waist he like is
that guy gonna die and he plowed through
that can you imagine how much [ __ ] his
wife was giving him I just don't think
he should coach anymore that's all I'm
trying to say yeah anyways so what are
your goals I've had the same goal for
[ __ ] 30 years one of the goals
drumming goal and I'm [ __ ] sick of it
am I ever gonna be able to play good
times bad times I'm once again trying I
you know it is I don't have the
stick-to-itiveness even though I keep
playing drums I keep doing what the [ __ ]
I love playing them but I just can't
focus on anything to get anything up to
speed I get everything up to like 80% I
could play good times bad times at about
75 bpms I'm [ __ ] 25 [ __ ] beat PMS
away
beats per minute for all you non
drummers out let's see I mean [ __ ]
find out what this is I should promise
you guys I'm gonna do a drum cover of
that song dressed as John Bonham I'll
put it on my patreon page when I finally
get it down let me see here
good times you [ __ ] bad times BPM beats
per minute BPM good times bad time BPM
what do you got what do you got what do
you say that what do you say there
clicking 94 oh [ __ ] I am 19 VPNs away
I'm just gonna keep playing it at 75
until 75 is a joke and if I have to move
up to 76 BPM so if I just have to
[ __ ] inch my way up like that that's
what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do cuz that that
cute little kid there who played it this
year I was just like what the you know
it's just that kid that belief that kid
with you laughs Lee you know what kills
me too it's 2 minutes and 46 seconds
long the bass drum lick that I that I
want to play is literally you know don't
Bowl dead put it up her up all right I
mean what does that take a second and a
half then the end of the song is Right
what is that
four seconds five seconds that is
[ __ ] help me up for 30 goddamn years
that's it
I'm gonna do a daily [ __ ] report a
weekly report make make sure I stick to
this where I'm at but you know it sucks
I'm gonna get up to maybe 76 BP [ __ ]
Em's right and then I'm gonna do this 10
[ __ ] day running Europe and by I come
back my foots gonna feel like some old
lady all right that's it everybody Merry
Christmas Happy Hanukkah happy Kwanzaa
god bless all yeah I hope you had a
great year I hope next year is even
better for you I hope you go after for
what you want in life because you only
live once goddamnit so what do you give
a [ __ ] if you bought
he's gonna be an old man saying I wanted
to do it and I tried and a life kicked
me in the nuts but at least I tried turn
my scrotum into a speed bag but I kept
coming back that'll be me someday on
YouTube ninety-year-old finally gets
good times bad times down then I cry and
keel over and die all right
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in on you
on Thursday oh ho ho